chez michel tout ce qui roule est une
passion et pourtant il n'est pas
mécanicien le bien menuisier de métier
reconverti dans la maquette il mêle son
amour du bois à sa passion première
une belle rencontre qui débute en 1990
quinze jours d'hiver j'ai pris mon
calepin au crayon mon maître j'ai
commencé à dessiner une traction
donc j'ai commencé par faire une
traction puis après j'ai fait une deux
chevaux j'ai fait une quatre chevaux et
le virus était l'enfer et une fois le
virus attrapé impossible d'en démordre
ce passionné exposé aujourd'hui dans son
petit musée environ 25 maquettes des
trésors de travail acharné
cette pièce la représenter à peu près
1200 heures de travail donc une année de
travail avec plus de 1000 pièces avec le
capot moteur
avec son moteur à l'intérieur et tout
est fonctionnel vous avez la direction
par le volant la pièce maîtresse
la voici une deux chevaux grandeur
nature évidemment la structure est
entièrement en bois équipée d'un moteur
d'origine
elle va même bientôt pouvoir rouler une
première en france
trois ans de travail pour aboutir à ce
petit bijou sur une pierre fine et que
c'est un rêve un rêve une réalité
un rêve de gosse qui ne fait pas les
choses à moitié
la climatisation on a la clé michel rêve
de voir bientôt rouler sa petite
merveille sur les routes de france et
finir c'est beau jour exposé dans un
musée